[Music]
when was the last time you were the
first person to do something the LPL has
never won before but that will change
evil world champion Arslan for most
people pioneering anything is a pipe
dream at best but me t walk the
fourteen-year-old deaf female streamer
who joined faze clan back in july as a
content creator if her rapid rise to
success is a sign of things to come
she's going to kicking some serious ass
in the near future she broke the glass
ceiling on a notoriously bro ask gaming
org and is also probably the first deaf
twitch partner and here's what she had
to say it's a big deal because I'm the
first deaf gamer to be one of the
partners on Twitch ever since twitch was
founded this has never happened now a
walk was born deaf so she can't rely on
in-game sounds to know where the enemy
is or anything else going on in the game
do you hear that yeah what is that
maybe judicial instead a walk uses sound
visualization which turns the game's
audio into visual cues and if you think
that sounds easy in a game like
fortnight where there's a ton of 3d
space think again bro this is so hard it
sounds like everything's under you or in
front of you there's no left or right
audio Wow he walks popularity steadily
rose after she joined twitch in January
of this year and it's pretty easy to see
why
[Music]
but he walks biggest viewer bump came
after popular stream art in the top man
hosted her channel this girl about to
host chat she's deaf okay so everyone go
give her a lot of love
he walks subscribers and live viewership
went from hundreds to thousands pretty
quickly and the gaming world was all
ears she's deaf and she's 13 she's
disgustingly good she's deaf like she
can't hear and she's insane she's so
good better than me is that she actually
does all this with no sound if I play
with no sound I don't have any eyes
oh my god you walk started playing with
some of Twitter's biggest names like
ninja dr. Lupo and liquid chap and face
clan really embraced Ewok even adding an
i-love-you sign language emoji to their
Twitter handle much
there's definitely exclusive stuff in
that she might be young but she's
definitely not shy he walked joined
other unhappy players calling out the
fortnight's devs on Twitter after they
added the brute mech to the game [ __ ]
death this game is ass and on top of it
you walk showing no signs of slowing
down she often talks about the next
generation chasing their dreams and just
going after it she's inspired many
people not only the death but also young
girls showing them that they can game -
that they can be skilled as anyone else
in this that they can keep up with the
boys that are gaming out there now it's
no secret that the Internet is a shitty
and toxic place sometimes but he watch
story stands out as a beacon of
positivity being a girl and being deaf
hasn't stopped me from anything you know
I am a pro player and I can continue to
do that you know my gender or my
identity doesn't matter you know what's
important is that I play she's turned
what many would see is a disadvantage
into an inspiring story for others and
that's how you do it first thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
you